ليلى احمد زاهر 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
بسرعه من غير تفكير حاضر ظهرت في صورك
الاخيره وانت نحيفه جدا كيف فقدت الوزن
حلو
عمرك خمس سنوات
لا انا كنت مبسوطه جدا الشباب
همم لو مثلا حكت لهم حاجه فتوتروا فممكن
يتعصبوا دقيق اكتر حاجه ابوكي فيها لا ما
بيعجبونيش بس بيقعدوا بيهددوني اللي هو
والله العظيم لو عملت كذا ثاني انا هاوريك
كده اوكي من واحد لعشره قديش سعادك على
الوصول للشهره بسرعه قوي
انت حلوه طبعا اكيد
الشعور انك حلوه يعني ما بعرفش ان ممكن حد
يقول على نفسه حلو قوي كده
كثير جاوب على هذا السؤال قال له نحن
حلوين اوكي يجي لك تحديث النشط جدا على
التيك توك وكثير بيعتبركم انفلوانزا
ودخيلات على التمثيل كيف بتردين
وانا صغيره حتى من وانا صغيره معروف ان
انا بامثل وكبرت واخذت بريك شويه في النصف
وهمم رجعت للتمثيل وتيك توك ده انا يعني
اللي خلاني اعمله ان انا كنت في الكرونه
كلنا كنا زهقانين كلنا كنا بنعمل توك حتى
انا الاكونت بتاعي ما كنتش عارفه
من صحابي اللي عمله لي اصلا وانا ما كنتش
متضايق اخوان انا عادي انا بانزل فيديوهات
زي زي اي احد واا
وبانزل زهقانه
يعني الحمد لله ههه
معهم همم هند صبري همم
دنيا سمير غانم حلوه
وكريم عبد العزيز واحمد عز اوكي حلوين
ممثل ونجمه او ممثله او نجمه سوشيال ميديا
الان هتدخلي عالم الغناء كمان همم
ممكن هتصيري مغنيه خلاص ممكن نقول لا يعني
هو انا يعني بغني وبامثل بس ما اعتقدش
هبقى مغنيه بس او ممثله بس يعني هنشوف
مثلا حفلات ليلى مش عارفه ممكن على فكره
ممكن جدا مع الوقت بس ما اعتقدش ان هو همم
كثير قوي طيب مقارنه جدا من اختك ملاك
ولكن مرت عليكم فتره خاصه
رد بسرعه السؤال ده لا كل اللي بريحي اااه
في واحده ربنا يسامحها ههه او او انا
بشكرها يعني لانها خليتني اقرب من اختي
اكثر هي كانت
بتوقع ما بيننا وانا كنت صغيره يعني وفي
الفتره دي ملك ما كانتش ما كناش عارفين ما
كانش فيه ايه وافكار منيشن ما بين قوي
فكانت الفتره دي يعني هي مش فاهماني وانا
لما باقول لها ان انا متضايقه من كذا تقول
لي لا انت غلطانه فهي مش بتريحني او مش
فاهماني صاحبتي دي كانت بتقول لي لا انت
صح او بتاع ايا كان انا كنت صح ولا غلط بس
همم في طريقه معينه تريحي بها اللي قدامك
وتعرفيني ان هو غلطان من غير ما تقفليه
اوكي هي كانت بتقفلني ما كناش عارفين
نتعامل مع بعض
صحبتي دي كانت بتريحني وبتاع فعلا انا كنت
همم يعني مستريحه مع صاحبتي ومتضايقه من
اختي انها مش معي صاحبتي كانت بتسخني على
اختي هي مش بتحبك هي هي هي وانا طبعا
غلطانه جدا جدا جدا لان ملك دي احلى واحده
في حياتي واقرب واحده لي واحده بتح يعني
الثانيه دي كانت بصراحه اا ربنا يبعد يعني
طبعا قطعت علاقتي بها تماما واا ربنا
يسامحها بقى ههه اكثر فكره مغلوطه عنك
اكثر فتره ايه فكره مغلوطه عنك فكره
مغلوطه عني همم
حاجه الناس بتقول عليا وهي مش صاحيه
همم
ممكن مثلا ان انا ممكن يقول ان انا تنكه
مش عارفه انا مش عارفه بس ممكن يعني
طيب اوكي ممكن يفهمه غلط يعني ممكن مش
صوره كده يقول لك لا دي تنكر اوكي
موهبه جدا جدا وشاطره جدا وهمم
وانا دايما بتفرج عليها بيبقى اللي هو مش
مصدقها هي ازاي بتعمل كل ده ازاي ما شاء
الله يعني بتغني وبتعمل استعراضات وبتمثل
وشيز يعني
شيز اميزنغ وهي مالتي تالنتد انا قائل لكم
يعني باشوفها نجمه كبيره جدا ونفسي في يوم
من الايام ابقى ان شاء الله ربعها يعني
مين اقرب صديقه لك في الوسط الفني انا ما
عنديش ناس قريبين
لما بيبقى عندي
بيبقوا اصحابي وباحبهم جدا جدا
وبعدين عرفت الخبر طبعا اتصدمت نزلنا من
الساحل على القاهره همم
رحتنا الجنازه وكل حاجه وبعدين رجعنا ثاني
ساحل علشان اهلي كلهم كانوا هناك وبتاع
فكان لازم ارجع
ف- اا انا بجد كنت مودي وحش جدا وكنت اللي
هو ممم لتالي حبسه نفسي في الاوضه ما كنتش
عايزه احتك بناس ومش عايزه تعمل مع احد
كنت همم
مرت ايام كثير قوي بابي مسافرنا عشان
نلبسط وهو بالنسبه له يعني مش عايز يشوفني
متضايقه وكده عملي مفاجاه وجاب لي
حفله عمرو دياب
وبس وبعدين انا ما كنتش عايزه اروح ايوه
انا بعشق حاجه اسمها عمرو دياب طبعا بس
انا نفسيا ما كنتش قادره اروح
فقعد يقول لي لا قوي اتحايل علي وقدرت انا
قوي ساعتها ان هو عمل كده عشاني عشان بس
ابقى مبسوطه عشان تغير جو وتخرجي»
فهد اللي صار يعني
طلعتي من الجنازه على الحفله بس مش هذا
انا عايز اقول لحد النهارده انا انا والله
العظيم وحياه ربنا انا لحد النهارده انا
مش مصدقه ان انا ماتت يلا يرحمها طبعا
ويرحمها الفنان الكبير سمير غانم زوج
المستقبل
[موسيقى]
روان بس ما بتلاقي وين الهجوم يعني هجوم
انا مش فاهمه والله بس انا باحبها وهي
بتحبني جدا الحمد لله فا- همم انت تنحب
بصراحه اغنيه تعبر عنك
همم لا ما اعرفش ما عندك واحده كده تحسي
تعبر عنك تعبر عني من ناحيه ايه بالضبط اي
شيء تحسي كده انه اه يعني انه تمثل لك
الاغنيه دي او كده همم
اذا انت رايقه بتحبي الدندنيها مش ضروري
انه بتعبر عنك بس بتحبيها يعني همم ممكن
اقول اكثر اغنيه معلقه معي دلوقت اسمها
جماله بتاعه جوزيف عطيه
منه
[ضحك]
على فكره
باخاف اصلا
اسرع شويه قلت ايه ده اوكي من واحد لعشره
قديش سعادك اسم والدك على تحقيق الشهره
والنجاح
[موسيقى]
يعني انا ممكن اقول 10 ان انا يعني هو هي
مش واثقه ولا اي حاجه بس موبايل راجل
محترم وتقيل ما شاء الله في التمثيل وكده
فانا حتى الناس يعني
لما بيشوفوني في الشارع بيقولوا لي
بيقولوا بنت احمد زاهر بيقول يعني زمان
يقولوا بنت ليلى احمد زاهر لحد دلوقت
بيقولوا البنت سوري بنت احمد زاهر لحد
دلوقت بيقولوا بنت احمد زي ايه عشان انا
بابايا ما شاء الله عليه احد جميل وكبير
فالناس عارفه ان انا بنته حتى بامثل او مش
بامثل الناس عارفه ان انا بنت احمد زاهر
ودلوقت بيقولوا لي ليلى احمد زاهر طبعا بس
الله يخليك هو يا رب في فترات او في فتره
في صغريك فرض عليك والدك التوقف تمثيل
ورفض اي عرض للعوده ما زعلت وقتها كده
جدا يعني بس انا كنت عايزه امثل انا كنت
شايفاه
يعني عارف ان انا موهوبه وقصده ان هو لا
بالعكس بس هو كان صح ان انا اخد بيت يعني
اوكي او يعني حسيتيه كانه بيحاول يقضي على
موته
روحي اعملت دراما كبيره
كان معدل صرفك على الملابس في الشهر
[ضحك]
الثاني من برنامج بدائته فنانه اخرى
بنتكلم طبعا
عن هذا القرار الحمد لله وانت موجوده الان
ما زعلت منه
لا ما زعلتش منه لان انا اي حد في مكانه
وانا قدرت ده يعني انا بالعكس صعب علي
يعني
هو كان خايف يمكن من بكره لان هو ما كانش
قادر دلوقتي ان هو يعمل كده بس ربنا كرم
الحمد لله
لما عمل الصح وسابني طبعا لان هو لو كان
قتلني او مشاني ههه شوف الويل لا وشوفي
ايش كان حقيقي
اوكي
لذيذه ومش فايه ملك شاطره جدا في التمثيل
شسفاري تعال انتد اوكي طيب كيف علاقتك
بالقراءه
ههه لا طبعا وحشه جدا
طب يعني ما بتقراي ابدا انا باكرهها ما
بحبش اقرا اه اوكي لو قدمتي برنامج حواري
مين اول نجم هتستضيف فيه وايش اول سؤال
هتسالي
ااااه
مين مين مش عارفه ممكن بقى
نقول مين استضيف احد وساله سؤال سؤال عامل
ازاي وانا مش عارفه سؤال انت حابه تعرفي
منه
ممكن استضيف هند صبري حلو اقول لها
انت ازاي شاطره كده
اعتقد هي مولوده كده او ما شاء الله عليها
جميله طيب شكرا قوي